نعود لاتصالنا بضيفنا الدكتور عطيه عبد
الله عطيه السكرتير العام لنقابه اطباء
السودان يرحب بك من جديد الدكتور كنتا
تتحدث قبل قليل عن خرق للهدنه بالاضافه
الى الظروف الصعبه التي تعانيها
المستشفيات في هذا التوقيت العصيب في
السودان
السوداني امام خيارين اما بالموت بالرصاص
او بالمرض نحن نجددني انا لكل المجتمع
الدولي لضغط على ترفيه الصرع لوقف هذه
الحرب العبثيه
نحاول مع زملائنا في المجتمع المحلي وايضا
لجان المقاومه في فتح مستشفيات طرفيه
وغرف للطوارئ اما حدث بالامس في مدينه
الكلاكله يعني مؤسف جدا مؤسف جدا استهداف
احياء سكنيه
للاسف الشديد يعني كل العدد الضحايا الذي
نتحدث عنه هو ان نتوقع انه يكون رقم بسيط
جدا اذا قرن بالهجمات التي نراها وايضا
نسمع عنها فتح الممرات الامنه يظل هو
مطلبنا الاوحد في هذه الظروف الحرجه حتى
نتمكن من
من اجلاء الجثث من الشوارع وايضا الوصول
الى المصابين وتقديم العون الطبي نحن نداء
كل اصدقاء السودان بالخارج ان يرسلوا جسور
الجويه وبريه وبحريه للاقادات الطبيه ما
ذكر تقريركم عدد من الامدادات يعني
المخازن امدادات لا يمكن الوصول اليها
وبعضها ايضا وايضا
يعني
النداءات كبيره جدا
ان مراكز الاولى لم تصمد اكثر من اربع
ايام من الان
باستدعايه الى امداد
جوي عاجل
والا سوف تتوقف تماما هذه يعني يؤسفنا جدا
ان يعني تتقازم احلامنا وان نطالب المجتمع
الدولي بان ان ان هذه الطائرات التي اتت
لاجل الاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب في السودان
تاتي فقط محمله بالمعدات الطبيه هذا الذي
نحلم نحلم به الان وهذا الذي نرجوه
المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
يقول بان المنظمه ناشدت الداعمين الدوليين
توفير مليار وسبع مئه مليون دولار لمساعده
السودان وتحديدا قطاعه الصحي ماذا تتوقعون
في هذا الاطار
نتوقع الاستجابه من المجتمع الدولي لانه
هذه المطالب مطالب انسانيه عاجله ولكن نحن
مطلبنا الى طرفي الصراع في السودان بفتح
الممرات الامنه حتى تصل هذه الامدادات الى
مستحقيها اذا وصلت هذه الامدادات الى الى
اي ميناء سواء بري او جوي او دون وصولها
الى المستشفيات سوف لن نستفيد منها نحن
الايقاع هذه
معتمده مع اي طرف من اطراف هذا الصراع
لتحقيق مطلبكم ام انكم اكتفيتم بالمشاهدات
لتوفير ممرات امنه
نحن ليس لدينا اي تواصل مباشر او غير
مباشر مع طرفي الصراع
نقالبهم فقط باسم الشعب السوداني ايقاف
هذه الحرب العباسيه فورا ليس لدينا اي
اتصال ولن يكون لدينا اي اتصال معهم هذه
الحرب هم من اشعلوها وهم يوقفها ليس لدينا
لدينا اي اتصالات معهم ولا اي رجاءات نحن
نطالب المجتمع الدولي بالضغط عليهم لوقف
هذه الحرب العبثيه يعني هم هم ووضعوا هذه
الشعب السوداني الطيب في هذا المازق
العسكري
الشعب الاني يموت يموت بالرصاص ويموت
بالمرض يعني
حتى الوساطات التي نتحدث عنها يتحدثون
عنها وايضا هذه الذي
وقف اطلاق النار الذي نسمعه عنه في
القنوات التلفزيونيه لا نراه على ارض
الواقع اتحدث اليك قبل قليل وسقط الدانه
في منطقه كما ذكرت لك في منطقه ام درمان
وايضا الطيران الحربي يحلق الان في جنوب
الخرطوم نتوقع بعض لحظات بعد ساعات ايضا
هنالك مزيد من
المصابين نحن نحاول مع كل اصدقاء
داخل نعم مع استمرار ايضا عمليات اجلاء
الاجانب الرعايه الاجانب من السودان تزداد
ايضا التحذيرات من تصاعد وتيره العنف
والمواجهات
وتساعد خطوره الوضع اذا غادر جميع الاجانب
السودان كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا السيناريو
القادم دكتور عطيه
نعم نحن اصدرنا بيان رسمي لذلك نحن نتوقع
تماما ان ينفرد طرفي الصراع بالشعب
السوداني
وايلات الحرب بعد خروج كل
الرعايه الاجانب الذين كانوا يشكلون
مراقبين الوضع الوضع الانساني في السودان
سوف نتوقع انقطاع الاتصال وانقطاع
الانترنت وايضا نتوقع الاسوء لذلك نحن
رجاءاتنا للمجتمع الدولي ان يعني هذا
الاجلاء لهذه الرعايه وهذا حقهم وهذا
متعارف عليه بكل الحروب ولكن نحن نطالب
فقط عليهم لايقاف هذه الحرب العبثيه
بالتزامن مع اخلاء رعاياهم من السودان نحن
لن نقف حاجز امام اخلاء الرعايه الاجانب
ونتمنى لهم سلامه الوصول الى اوطانهم ولكن
كانوا يعني يشكلون على طرفيه الصلاح سوف
تزود بمجرد خروج من السوره وهو مؤشر خطير
وخطير جدا الان هذه هي الهدنه الرابعه بين
الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
اتهامات بخرق هذه الهدنه من طرفي الصراع
انتم
كنقابه اطباء السودان كيف
استفدتم ان صح التعبير من هذه الاوقات منذ
بدايه سريان هذه الهدنه حتى الان الى اي
مدرسه استفدتم في
اسعاف او مساعده المحتاجين طبيا ومحتاجين
علاجيا في هذا التوقيت
ان لم تكن هنالك اي هجمه منذ صبيحه الخامس
عشر من ابريل حتى الان كل الذي يتحدثون
عنه نسمع عنه في القنوات التلفزيونيه وفي
البيانات المنتشره لم يتوقف صوت الرصاص لم
يتوقف عزيزه الطائرات كل الذي يتحدثون عنه
انما هو خداع للمجتمع الدولي لم نستفيد من
اي وقت للطاقه النار ولم يكن هناك باي وقت
اطلاق النار بهذه الطريقه حتى الان هذا
الوقف الرابع او الخامس والسادس حتى
العاشر والمائه ان ان صحت هذه البيانات لن
يكون له اي تاثير على ارض الواقع ما لم
يكون هنالك يعني
بضمانات بضمانات والواقع لذلك نحن رسالتنا
الامم المتحده ليس فقط ان توقع على بيانات
وانما ايضا
ان تكون شريكا على ارض الواقع في انزال
هذه الهدن على على ارض الواقع
حينما سوف يكون الكوادر الطبيه هم ايضا
عرضه
اليوم يعني لدينا عدد من
هم تعرضوا
للاصابات المباشره وغير المباشره وهم الان
جزء منهم حالته خطيره في المستشفيات هذا
الوضع وايضا تعرض عدد سته اسعاف للضربه
المباشره استهداف المباشر وتم نهب باسعاف
ايضا باللغه الارقام بلغه الارقام عدد
المستشفيات التي توقفت عن الخدمه وعدد
المستشفيات التي ما تزال تعمل وماذا
قدرتها في استيعاب الوضع الحالي
نحن لدينا 57 مستشفى توقف عن العمل تماما
لدينا 19 مستشفى تم اخلاقه لاسباب امنيه
وتم يعني لاسباب من بينها انه طرفي الصراع
يعني احتلوا هذه المواقع الطبيه
وشكلوا منها مصادر او انطلاق
لعملياتهم العسكريه 13 مستشفى تم
استهدافهم مباشر اما بالقذايف العسكريه كل
الذين نتحدث عنه انما هو بسيط نحن نتوقع
ان يكون الارقام اكبر من ذلك جزء هذا الذي
وصلنا اليه من المستشفى عدد متوقع ان يكون
كبير وكبير جدا في هذه الظروف التي نعيشها
الان
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه
عبد الله عطيه السكرتير العام لنقابه
اطباء السودان شكرا لك